I went back, to
Africa this time.
Exploration had taken on
a different modality here.
We were gonna explore
the upper headwaters
of the Okavongo, the
Cuito river catchment
that flows out of the
Angolan highlands.
Steve Boyes,
another NG explorer,
took us to the Angolan highlands
after basically 30
years of civil war,
15 years of peace at this point,
to study this unexplored
river catchment.
One of the reasons it's
still unexplored is
because after wars,
there are remnants
and land mines are one of those.
What happens here
is that these areas
are kept off limits
by the land mines.
It's a very tragic catch-22,
and as soon as the
land mines are cleared,
people move in
immediately, right?
And the first thing they do is
they cut down all the trees,
and when they cut
down all the trees,
they use that for charcoal,
then they plant cassava,
which lasts about
three years, maybe,
and then you've got basically
a dead plot of land,
so you're left between, well,
do we leave the land mines in?
Of course, you can't do that,
but as soon as you do it,
you look at massive
deforestation,
and that's happening
all the time.
There's no clearcut answer.
This is the headwaters.
We were doing what's
called a source to sand
because the delta, or
the water of the delta
actually doesn't flow to an
ocean; it's very unusual.
Every year, the delta
itself in Botswana floods
with 11 cubic
kilometers of water.
It's the beating heart
of southern Africa.
When it floods, all
the migrations come in.
When it dries up, disperse,
and it's very important
for southern Africa,
so this is the source.
The idea was to put on
mokoros, or dugout canoes,
on that river flowing
out of the bottom
and float the entire length.
There was not enough
water to float.
It was good for me at the time.
I was feeling so much anger
and pain and confusion,
I'd just get in the
water with crocodiles
and just start
chopping at stuff.
People were like, "Cory,
don't chop at that.
"You're going upstream."
I'm like, oh, okay, turn around.
Anyway, you know, we had this
opportunity to finally put
the mokoros in the
water and float them,
and this is what it looked
like in those upper regions.
You can see the mokoros down
in the bottom of the frame,
this crystal water,
but it was slow going.
On the right side here
is a burned section.
On the left is a
healthy section.
The right side is where
people have come in
and burned it down to flush
game and hopefully regenerate.
Unfortunately, all that does is
it destroys the root
structure, and when it rains,
it pushes more sand into the
river, destroying the flow.
We were also looking at
these huge blockages.
It was drudgery, it was
cutting through these things.
I mean, we're in the
water with crocodiles,
snakes, blisters, heat
stroke, all of the things
that make exploration
really not fun at all,
and this is days upon days,
and why do you do this?
That becomes the question,
and the answer is,
I mean, you have to do it.
We have to understand
these landscapes
because so many
people and animals
and plants are
connected to them.
We're all connected, right?
We have to care for each other,
so exploration becomes about
showing why it's important.
What we found, six new to
science species of fishes,
dozens of new flora, reptiles.
We were creating a holistic
story of the river catchment
and we found the
most bio-diverse
unexplored corridor on Earth.
These were the first people
that didn't run from us,
which makes sense.
Why would you not run from
12 white dudes on mokoros?
Not a good sight to see, but
these people were concerned.
They were concerned that
the government didn't know
they were there, and
quite rightly so.
The government didn't
know they were there.
The government hadn't
been there in 40 years.
The last time was
soldiers passing through,
and what I started
to realize was that
their concerns in the
bush were no different
than the concerns of the people
in Rwanda, the capital city.
This is a very oil-rich place,
and there is enough money
to create a collective
well-being in this country,
but everybody's concerned
about their own well-being
because the country itself
is concerned about resources,
so as the oil prices, as
the oil crunch happens,
water becomes sort of a focus
because it can be used
for all sorts of things,
hydroelectricity,
mineral extraction,
there's all sorts of things
that this water can be used for,
and everybody's
concerns are the same.
What happens to our water?
This was really a
story about water,
not about just one river,
not just about the delta,
at least not for me.
This is a story
about what happens
to the artisanal fisheries
after overfishing with
industrial fishing,
what happens to
subsistence fishing,
what happens when governments
think first of resources
and how does that
affect us downstream?
And it's not just us, it's
not just humans, we know that.
It's big cats, and we
have a Big Cat Initiative.
It's the water that
feeds the big cats.
It's the aquatic life.
It's everything from
the crocs to the fishes
to the algae to
the grass, right?
Goes all the way down.
To the megafauna, the
elephants, the hippos,
the rhinos, the
buffalo, all of it,
all the way down to the
absolute tiniest, the termites.
All of this is this
interconnected web,
and the story doesn't stop
and start with one system.
It expands beyond it, and
where do we fit in in there?
How does the human
element come to play?
Because these people, the sand
people, don't exist anymore.
This is for tourism;
they dress up
and show tourists what
it used to be like.
In fact, Chris Johns,
who's sitting right here,
did one of the last stories
when this was actually genuine,
and so it's stopped since
then, so what's happened?
The only thing I
can think of was
a Norman Maclean quote,
and it's very simple.
Eventually, all
things merge into one
and a river runs through it,
and I think that's very poignant
when I move forward here.
This is the last sad picture
of my wife I'm gonna show you,
but I want to just
talk briefly about it.
It was funny, in all
of my assignments,
it's only when I totally
give myself up to it,
when I totally give
myself over to it,
when I surrender, do I
actually start to see,
and it was the same
with my marriage.
Only when I totally surrendered,
only when she
totally surrendered,
did we actually see each
other for who we were,
but by that time,
it was too late.
We burned things down and
hopefully, they regrow.
It was serendipitous
that this last spring,
my sponsor, Eddie Bauer, asked
if I would like to
return to the mountains,
the place where this
fracture started,
the place where the
avalanche had taken my life
and done that with it,
and I said, of course.
I'd love to go back
to the mountains.
Where are we going? Everest.
Okay, that sounds like a plan.
I'm excited to go back and
try to reconcile all of this,
although I wasn't really
thinking that at the time,
but I knew I had to go back,
I knew I had to go back to
the mountains, and I know,
trust me, I know it's
self-indulgent for me,
a white American male
to go back to Everest
to try to figure my
(bleep) out, like, come on.
Stick with me,
don't walk out yet.
I went back with a guy
named Adrian Ballinger
and the goal was to try to
climb Everest without oxygen.
I didn't go as a photographer.
We were using, as Alice
mentioned, Snapchat.
We were doing something
called EverestNoFilter,
and we were bringing
people along
up Everest as we climbed it,
and we had classrooms
checking in with us,
talking about physiology
and altitude and geography.
It was a very, very
cool experience
to watch it sort of
grow organically.
We just wanted to take
people along and show
what it was like to actually
be on a real expedition.
So I took very few photos.
This is actually one of the
ones that I really loved
and there aren't that many.
In fact, I'm only
gonna show you four,
and this is the last one.
This is at 28,950 feet,
so just about 100 feet,
vertical feet below Everest's
summit on May 24th, 2016,
and Adrian had turned around
much earlier in the morning,
and I was alone, I had
just passed these guys.
That's right, I passed people
without oxygen, it's cool.
I'm not arrogant, what?
I just passed 'em and I turned
around and I looked back
and I knew I was gonna
be on the summit alone,
which is very rare, vanishingly
rare for Everest these days.
I knew I was gonna be
up there by myself,
and when I got there,
I cried for a second
'cause I'm a crier, and I
stood up as tall as I could
and I just reached up into space
'cause that's as close
as I'm ever gonna get.
I'm not gonna go back
and be an astronaut,
and at the time, I
thought, you know,
maybe this is the punctuation,
maybe this is the end.
Maybe this is the
end of the darkness.
I've climbed my way out;
I was the phoenix rising.
I've now proven that I
can overcome anything
and that is, you
know, I'm good, done.
Put a stamp on it, send it away,
and what actually happened,
and I didn't know it at the
time was that was the point
where my biggest
lesson was to come,
that I can run from everything,
and I'm good at
it, and we all are.
I can run as hard and
as far and as fast
from the things, my
demons that bother me,
that eat me inside, I can go
to the top of the (bleep) world
and they're right there with me,
and that is a collective
human experience.
We cannot run from
our issues, ever.
The point is to turn
into them and face 'em.
That's what we have to do.
You can go there, and they're
still right there with you.
So, you know, my life
has never been normal.
I started in these mountains
and that's what brought me up.
I'm not a particularly
talented human,
but I'm willing to
try and keep going.
It's hard work, it's not about,
I take out a camera and
I get a perfect picture.
It doesn't work that way.
Chris knows that
better than anybody.
It is one of the hardest
things that you can do.
I started with the mountains,
and the mountains
brought me to adventure,
and adventure and
exploration started
to change the way
I saw the world.
I didn't care as much about
this as I cared about this,
what's happening to the planet,
so this exploration gave me
a different lens through
which to view it,
and what I've
learned from this is
that we're looking
for solutions.
Humans are looking
We want answers to everything.
How do we stop this,
how do we stop that?
What do we do, what are the
solutions for climate change?
And know that those
solutions are different
than the solutions for the
global corrosion of culture.
They're very, very different.
How do we solve that?
And those solutions
are different
than the ones we
need for conflicts.
How do we deal with that?
And of course, those solutions
are very different than
those that we need to help
those that are affected
by conflict, former child
soldiers, areas like Aleppo.
How do we deal with that?
What are the solutions?
There's a lot of questions
facing our world right now,
and there aren't any
real clear answers.
One thing that I believe is
that we are all tied together,
and by all tied
together, I'm not talking
about a hippie
oneness of the world.
I'm talking about physically,
everything relies
on everything else.
It really does, in
our day to day lives,
and we need to pay
more attention to that.
How do we honor that bond?
'Cause we will find solutions.
We are very, very good
at finding solutions.
That's what humans do.
We have very big brains and
we put band-aids on things.
As a generalist, my
goal with my photography
is not to focus on one thing.
I don't wanna be
great at one thing.
I wanna tell multiple stories
through multiple different
voices and lenses.
I wanna step back.
I wanna ask the question,
not how do we solve
the problems we have?
How do we stop
creating the problems?
What's the answer to that?
Why do I get up here and
talk about divorce and PTSD
and infidelity and adventure
and confuse the whole topic?
I mean, I've talked
about alcoholism,
I've talked about
sustainability.
You guys are like, what
is the through line?
I mean, I get it, dude, but
what is the through line?
Where are you going with this?
The through line is this.
We are the stewards, and
every single choice we make
has a consequence,
every single one,
and that is very
important to remember.
I'm 35 years old; I
don't have the answers.
I can tell you to ride bikes.
I can tell you to eat less meat.
I can tell you to
take shorter showers.
not use plastic bags.
Don't use straws, you know.
Buy a Prius,
whatever you can do.
You guys know that.
We do need initiatives
like Pristine Seas.
like Big Cats.
We do need to focus that, but
those honestly are band-aids
on existing wounds,
so what is the virus
and how do we address that?
And honestly, honestly,
I think the answer is
much, much simpler
than we're making it,
but I'm not audacious
enough to say that,
so I'm gonna let somebody else
say it in different words.
He's a little smarter
than me, not much.
You might've heard of him;
his name's Carl Sagan.
Anyway, that little dot there,
if you haven't seen this before,
this photograph is
called the Pale Blue Dot,
and that dot in that
sunbeam is us, that's Earth.
That was taken from
3.7 billion miles away
in February 14, 1990,
and this is what Carl,
my buddy Carl had
to say about this.
"Look again at that dot.
"That's here, that's
home, that's us.
"On it, everyone you
love, everyone you know,
"everyone you've ever heard of,
"every human being who ever
was lived out their lives.
"The aggregate of our
joy and suffering,
"thousands of
confident religions,
"ideologies and
economic doctrines.
"Every hunter and forager,
every hero and coward,
"every creator and
destroyer of civilization,
"every king and peasant,
every young couple in love,
"every mother and
father, hopeful child,
"inventor and explorer,
every teacher of morals,
"every corrupt politician,
every superstar,
"every supreme leader,
every saint and sinner
"in the history of our
species lived there,
"on a mote of dust
suspended in a sunbeam.
"The Earth is a very small
stage in a vast cosmic arena.
"Think of the endless cruelties
visited by the inhabitants
"of one corner of this pixel
on the scarcely distinguishable
"inhabitants of
some other corner,
"how frequent their
misunderstandings,
"how eager they are
to kill one another,
"how fervent their hatreds.
"Think of the rivers
of blood spilled
"by all those
generals and emperors
"so that in glory and
triumph, they could become
"the momentary masters
of a fraction of a dot.
"Our posturings, our
imagined self-importance,
"the delusion that we have
some privileged position
"in the universe are challenged
by this point of pale light.
"Our planet is a lonely speck
"in the great
enveloping cosmic dark.
"In our obscurity,
in all this vastness,
"there is no hint
that help will come
"from elsewhere to
save us from ourselves.
"The Earth is the only world
known so far to harbor life.
"There is nowhere else, at
least in the near future,
"to which our species
could migrate.
"Visit, yes, settle, not yet.
"Like it or not, for the moment,
"the Earth is where
we make our stand.
"It has been said
that astronomy is
"a humbling and
character-building experience.
"There is perhaps no
better demonstration
"of the folly of human conceits
"than this distant
image of our tiny world.
"To me, it underscores
our responsibility
"to deal more kindly
with one another,
"and to preserve and
cherish the pale blue dot,
"the only home
we've ever known."
Now, think about
that for a second.
Carl Sagan was pretty smart,
but he didn't end with policy.
He didn't end with
carbon emissions.
He didn't end with rainforests.
He didn't end with any of that
'cause those are the wounds.
That's what's happened.
He ended with kindness.
It's the most simple thing,
because when we act kindly
towards one another, in this
city especially right now,
when we act kindly
towards one another,
we hear each other, we treat
each other with respect.
We might not agree, and
when there are abuses,
we stand up for them,
but we treat each other
with kindness and respect,
and the root of that,
dare I say it as 35 year old man
who's done all sorts
of horrible things,
the root of that
is the one thing
that makes us
different as an animal.
It's the single most
important thing we do.
It's unique to us,
and that is love.
That's what we do,
and that, in and of
itself, is where we start.
So without saying too much
more, I love you guys very much
and thank you for
sharing this with me.
(audience applauding)